hi there today we'll look at direct
feedback alignment scales to modern deep
learning tasks and architectures by
Julia Looney Yakko poopley
Francois Boniface and Flo Hong
chrysocolla so this paper on a high
level it replaces the back propagation
algorithm in deep learning architectures
with this algorithm called direct
feedback alignment which is more
biologically plausible the algorithm has
been around for a while but it hasn't
yet been shown to be applicable to
really modern big deep learning
architectures and then perform on par
with back prop on modern deep learning
tasks this paper as I understand is the
first one to demonstrate that it can do
that so this is very much an engineering
paper and applied paper and we're going
to mostly go into direct feedback
alignment as such and I don't think
we're gonna go too much into what the
actual empirical findings are because
and they even though they're impressive
and it's a good piece of engineering I
think they can be summarized pretty much
by it it works not yet on par with
backpropagation but into a promising
direction all right as always if you
like content like this consider sharing
it out and leaving a like and tell me in
the comments what you like of course
subscribe if you aren't yet that that is
you know essential otherwise how are we
gonna hear from me in the future okay
let's dive in they say despite being the
workhorse of deep learning the back
propagation algorithm is no panacea it
enforces sequential layer updates thus
preventing efficient parallelization of
the training process furthermore it's
biological plausibility is being
challenged alternative schemes have been
devised yet under the constraints of
synaptic asymmetry none have scaled to
modern deep learning tasks and
architectures here we challenge this
perspective and study the applicability
of direct feedback alignment to neural
view synthesis
systems geometric learning and natural
language processing in contrast with
previous studies limited to computer
vision tasks our findings show that it
successfully trains a large range of
state-of-the-art deep learning
architectures with performance close to
fine-tuned back propagation at variance
with common beliefs our work supports
that challenging tasks can be tackled in
the absence of weight transport so
there's a lot to unpack in this
particular abstract right here so first
of all what's the problem with back
propagation back propagation they have
they have two quarrels right here first
of all it's preventing efficient
parallelization of the training process
so what does that mean so in back
propagation I pretty sure you all know
it's basic back propagation but you have
an input to a neural network and the
neural network is a bunch of layers so
the input will travel layer by layer and
at the end you'll get some output and
your output Y hat
let's call here what the neural network
thinks the let's say it's a classifier
thinks that the class of this a
particular X should be now in the data
set you have your true label and then
you compare that to your output label
and you can compute a loss function now
the whole question of the back
propagation algorithm is how do I need
to change my layers of the neural
network in order to make the loss as
small as possible and for that you can
use back propagation that means you can
take that loss and you can back
propagate it down the layers in order to
update each layer individually so the
first problem they have here with the
back propagation algorithm and it's not
I mean it's kind of a secondary problem
but it is that is sequential so in order
to update this layer right here you need
to have already back propagated to this
layer and then you need to back
propagate further to this and to this
layer so it's a sequential task you need
to back propagate down the layers again
whereas what is more plausible but what
would be more efficient if
we could somehow update all the layers
in parallel but this is a minor quarrel
the bigger one is that backpropagation
isn't biologically plausible
we know that in real neurons you have
your dendrites your inputs any of your
axon and the signal only travels in one
direction we don't know of a feedback
mechanism in true neurons in the brain
that would allow for information sort of
to flow in the opposite direction there
is there is information flowing the
opposite direction but it's it's I guess
I think it's too slow and it's so it's
not really it can't be
there's no analogous way of back
propagation there's no nothing in the
brain that would take the role of the
back propagation algorithm specifically
if each layer is characterized by a
weight matrix right here what back
propagation does is it uses the
transpose of that weight matrix to back
propagate so these these arrows to the
front right here they use the weight
matrices and these arrows to the back
they use the transpose of the weight
matrices so the transpose of the weight
matrices sort of relay the information
of what needs to change that would be
the law what needs to change to make the
loss as small as possible they relay
this information down to the other
layers and we don't know of any
biological analogy analogy to this
mechanism right here this transpose it
acts as sort of a layer inverse and that
is called weight transport so weight
transport means that you can you can do
something like the transpose of the
weights basically to carry to bring
information from the next layer back to
this layer and in biology we don't have
this and in direct feedback alignment we
don't have this either so direct
feedback alignment the next thing here
in this abstract
is the algorithm that they are going to
apply here direct feedback alignment and
we'll go into what it is but it is more
biologically plausible in that what it
does is it takes the loss somehow and it
distributes it globally to all of these
layers like this and it does so without
requiring these transposes and also
without requiring these sequential steps
so both of their proposed problems here
would be solved by this they say they
say that in contrast with previous
studies limited to computer vision tasks
so what people have tried to do is they
have tried to apply this DFA algorithm
to computer vision tasks but in computer
vision most architectures are cnn's and
as i understand it as far as I
understand it DFA can only right now be
applied to linear layers so something
that is W X plus B and then a
non-linearity I cannot even though you
can write the CNN as like a linear layer
with constraints as I read this paper I
think to interpret that you can only
apply DFA to fully connected layers or
things that look kind of like fully
connected layers so what they're gonna
do in their experiments is they're gonna
take these big architectures like
transformers and replace parts of them
with the parts that act as fully
connected layers with the with DFA
updates so well they're not gonna
replace the layers but they're gonna
replace the backpropagation part of it
with DFA updates it remains to say that
they still use back propagation at some
places where they can't replace it the
updates with DFA and that means where
the layer isn't you know for the
connected layer or I guess is too big
they some have to make it work so often
they will not update for example the
embedding layers and things like this
okay so what they're saying is they go
away from computer vision tasks because
if you go to computer vision
and CNN's rule that world right you can
only do four feet forward layers fully
connected layers you're gonna lose
already and so yeah it's kind of an
unfair fight in that in that sense but
even an absence of that they say we
apply this to neural view synthesis
recommender systems geometric learning
and natural language processing so these
are quite diverse tasks and they're
going to be quite diverse architectures
that they are applying to for example in
geometric learning I believe they do
graph neural networks and they're there
they replace the if usually in graphical
networks there are fully connected
layers that connect the two diverted
sees and the edges together and compute
properties of them so that's a pretty
good point for using DFA right because
what you're looking for is state of the
art tasks and architectures that still
employ fully connected layers because
they're your algorithm can shine okay so
that's it and they basically show that
this is performance is close to
fine-tuned backpropagation all right so
what is DFA what is these direct
feedback alignment and for that I
actually want to jump papers right here
and go to this other paper that
describes DFA in a bit in a bit not more
detail but in a graphic fashion so this
paper right here direct feedback
alignment provides learning in deep
neural networks by RL northland sorry no
cloned shows some theoretical properties
about DFA now I don't want to go into
the theory right here or in the math but
I mainly like his paper for this
particular graphic right here so in the
backpropagation algorithm as you can see
you forward propagate using these weight
matrices and then you back propagate
using the transpose of the weight
matrices
now one step after that is this thing
right here it's called feedback
alignment it's
not the same thing as a direct feedback
alignment in feedback alignment you
simply say well I won't back prop using
these transposes because I can't because
that's not biologically possible what
I'll do is I'll use other matrices and
these other matrices are going to be
random matrices and by random matrices
we really mean a matrix that is of you
know the correct shape the same shape as
this W transpose but each entry is going
to be sampled from a like a random
Gaussian right now I don't mean like the
distribution of gaussians but you fix
this matrix once at the beginning of
training by sampling from Gaussian and
then you leave it there and that's going
to be the matrix that you use for
relaying the signal back through the
layers
now you might protest and say wait
that's not gonna work
because specifically this thing right
here it you know that you need to know
the way it's here to know what you need
to change in the lower layers you need
to somehow have that information in
there how are you gonna know what to
change and that's a valid question and I
will give my opinion of why this works
okay in a second in two seconds first
this is feedback alignment so simply use
a random matrices to back propagate so
to say and then you have direct feedback
alignment and direct feedback alignment
goes a step further because in feedback
alignment you still do this in a
sequential manner direct feedback
alignment simply takes whatever the top
change should be the little change to
the top layer so how do I need to change
the top layer and it back propagates
that in a global fashion to all the
layers directly using random matrices
okay and then this is a we're not going
to look at today because that's not
relevant for this other paper but I hope
you can sort of see the overview here so
let's go back
scroll cross cross cross cross cross
cruel okay so here is the mathematical
formulation of all of this and it pays
to look at it to understand what's going
on so they characterize a neural network
right here as having n layers each
neural network is the following each
neural each layer takes whatever is the
output of the last layer multiplies it
by a weight matrix and that's going to
be your a quantity you put a through a
non-linearity to obtain the next layers
input ok so the H is the output of this
layer and the input of the next layer at
the very end your last output is going
to be your estimation of the labels so
your last non-linearity is probably
going to be something like a a softmax
or something like this ok so how can we
how can we have this as a concept in our
heads if you have the neural network
right here what you want to do is you
wanna forward prop always using your
weight matrix W and then your
non-linearity of that particular layer
and then the last in the last layer you
get your Y hat as we saw before now the
question is how can we adjust how can we
adjust this W right here to make Y hat
more into the direction of Y and here
it's in here it's useful to think of the
last layer as a vector output like
usually we think of the loss function
but in all of these algorithms they
always start with the derivative of the
loss function with respect to the last
layer output so a Y and a Y is here
right before the non-linearity if you
remember this was F of a Y and this here
I guess is the softmax so if this is a
classifier the a Y here those are the
lockets
and that's the output of your last layer
so it it instead of having y and y hat
right now sorry y hat right here
it pays to maybe think of the output as
a vector and the desired output as
another vector and the desired output is
of course going to be one hot vector in
the case of in the case of a
classification but it you know if you
think of it like this then you will
recognize okay I need to change if this
is my estimated output and I want to
achieve this output I need to change it
into this direction right to get more
into the same direction as the output I
want the entire question now becomes how
do I tell the lower layers about this
change right here this is the change
that I want to make in the lower layers
how do I get the lower layers such that
they provide me with that signal with
with the green signal instead of the red
signal so I need to propagate this blue
difference in the back propagation
algorithm you can simply ask the system
right so we've built entire frameworks
on being able to back propagate
tensorflow Pytor jacks whatever because
with back propagation we can simply ask
the system this question so here is how
should I change the weights of my layer
to make the loss smaller you can just
ask that you can say what's the gradient
of the loss with respect to the to my
weights and the night negative sign here
is because you want to make the loss
smaller okay and that is going to be a
straightforward calculation how does
that calculation go it's going to
involve this right here is the last
layers output this right here as you can
see
over here is going to be this is going
to be whatever comes back from the
backpropagation so in backpropagation
you always have to think of if you want
to update these weights you need two
quantities you need whatever comes from
the bottom or came from the bottom
during the forward pass and whatever
comes from the top
during the backward pass and this
quantity here is going to be the one
that came from the top and it's
basically how you need to change the
next layer in order to make the loss
happier and by using this right here you
pull it back to this layer so how we do
I need to change this layer and here you
see that dreaded transpose of that
weight matrix this is what we can't do
in biology but this is what back
propagation does so it pulls back how
you need to change the next layer it
pulls it back to this layer so this
quantity right here is basically how do
I need to change the output of this
particular layer in order to make the
loss happier and then you multiply it by
the signal that comes from the bottom
and that will give you how you need to
change your weights okay so the green
part is how does the output of the layer
need to change and the multiplied by the
blue part it's how do the weights need
to change and of course the
non-linearity is in there as well but
let's let's just leave the non-linearity
away because it's really not important
for this particular thing so this is
what backprop does what does DFA do DFA
here again asks how should I change the
weights of light your eye and DFA says
well first you need to compute this
thing right here this is you see the
derivative of the loss with respect to a
Y now a Y is the output of the last
layer these are in in our case for
example your log it's okay note that
this is still a gradient so it's not
like we can
differentiate anymore we simply can't do
backpropagation from layer to layer okay
so this is the quantity how do we need
to change the last layers output and
we're going to take that and simply feed
it through this random matrix and then
multiply again let's leave this away
multiply it by the by this thing right
here so if I get my colors correct like
this again you have your neural network
you want to update these weights the
green is what comes from the top now it
doesn't come from the next layer but the
green actually comes from all the way at
the end sorry you can't see that I still
have to get used to that new frame of
view so the green comes all the way from
the end and the blue comes from down
here okay
so this is weird right because
especially because this is just
modulated by a random matrix so how can
this possibly work that's the question
and I you know I had some thoughts but I
haven't read too much about it so I
might be completely wrong or this might
be completely known in the community I
have no idea I'll just give my opinion
right here so first of all you have to
see if you compare this to back prop so
what's actually changing is this green
part right here right we agree that this
is the thing that's changing and what
did we say does the green part mean the
green part basically tells you how do
you how should the output of this layer
change okay by adjusting the weights in
the direction of the thing on the right
side of the equality sign you're going
to change the output of the layer into
the direction of that green part now in
back propagation the green part
basically tells you how should the
output of this layer change in order to
make the loss as happy as possible now
we don't have that anymore here we
simply change the output of the layer
into the into the interaction of a
random transformation of the of the
change we would like to have in the
output now okay that's the the first
thing is we understand what's different
and we understand what the green
quantity means green quantity means how
should the output of our layer change
okay second thing if you look at the
last layer of a neural network that that
log its layer right what does it
actually do let's say we had that's a
three dimensional last layer which means
you have three classes right if your
last layer is three dimensional
you have three classes each axis
represents one class because you encode
the classes as one hot vectors so this
might be see the class label equals zero
this might be C equals one this might be
C equals two if you have something that
you forward propagate through your
neural network and let's say it comes
out to be like this what would you
classify that as now you classify that
as the whatever class has the the
biggest inner product with that vector
which would be the C equals zero class
right here and what is this quantity
going to be how should you update this
output in order to make the loss happier
now that depends on your true label but
let's say your true label is actually
the zero label now what you want to do
is you want to update that thing in two
direction here right such that it is
more aligned with the axis so what
happens if you pull that back through a
random matrix now the thing you have to
know about random matrices like this is
that they do approximately preserve
distances and angles so technically if
you pull this back what you're going to
induce is another coordinate system in
that other space now this can be a
higher or a lower dimensional space I
frankly I don't care
but what you're going to induce is a
coordinate system and what do you pull
through that B matrix so this is the BI
matrix you fix it right this is really
important you fix it at the beginning of
training it's always the same it
preserves distances and angles
approximately you pull back that
quantity which is the okay my colors are
all screwed which is the green arrow
over here you pull back this green arrow
here so what does it mean what so the
output right here the output vector that
came from the lower layers right that's
you forward propagated that through your
network so maybe in this layer it
actually pointed here we don't know but
let's say it pointed here if we pull
back the green thing it might point here
okay now this is since it's around the
matrix we don't know we know that the
angle is approximately preserved okay
but you know that and these lengths are
approximately preserved with relative to
each other but it doesn't really tell
you too much so why is this useful and
to see why it's useful you need to
consider other inputs we don't just in
out input this one vector we input a
whole bunch of data now let's consider
two other vectors so first I want to
consider this this blue vector right
here now
the blue vector is also going to have a
label of zero so what does the blue
vectors update look like the blue vector
is going to be pulled into this
direction and I also want to consider
this red vector right here the red
vector is of class one so what does the
red vectors update going to look like
like this and if I consider now the red
and the blue vector in this space right
let's I just draw them at random like so
okay
what I do know actually that's that's
for consistent draw the blue somewhere
here and the red somewhere here what I
do know is that the angles and distances
are preserved so what is the green thing
going to look like the update for the
blue vector is going to be something
like this and the update for the red
vector is going to maybe be something
like this you know away from from those
so what is happening in that lower space
you'll notice that the two vectors that
are supposed to be in the same class
this and this they are going to be
pulled together now the direction
they're pulled in that's determined by
this random matrix but we know they're
going to be pulled together because they
are pulled together in this space in the
final space okay and they're going to be
pulled apart from the red vector okay
because that red vector is going to be
pulled towards a different class in the
in the last space and since the
distances and angles are approximately
preserved it's going to be pulled away
from these in in this space so what this
induces in my opinion is some sort of it
induces this coordinate system where if
you make the last layer acts as a line
because you want to classify it it kind
of clusters things that belong in the
same class in these previous weight
spaces right and because and if you do
this layer by layer so if you do this in
layer K and then you make the job easier
for any layer k plus one that's in
between here right because they're now
the things in the same classes are
already together pretty okay now you map
it through a weight and the
non-linearity they might you know
intertwine a bit again but there's
they're more together than they would be
otherwise so you make the job for the
next layer easier which means that next
layer
can also can even better cluster things
and what you'll end up with in this last
layer is the is a basically a clause or
next to last letter is basically a
clustering where everything that's
supposed to be in the same class is
together and far apart from each other
and since the last layer is the
classification layer it's going to have
a really easy job separating those
classes and performing good
classification so that's what I think is
happening in this algorithm so even
though the layers don't know how to
change to help the last layer by the
fact that these random matrices and
induce a clustering together you know by
back propagating these updates here it
helps the last layer make it makes its
job really easy and you know that's all
the classifier needs and I want to I
want to show again this is my opinion
this is not anything of value it's just
my hypothesis of why something like this
could work I want to show you in this
paper that I've shown you before right
here they do actually do these
experiments with DFA and they show that
you can see top row shows feature
obtained with backpropagation bottom row
shows features obtained with DFA I think
these are input and features I'm not
sure where exactly they are in the
network but you can see that this
clustering clearly emerges so oh yeah
here from left to right input images
first hidden layer second hidden layer
third hidden layer so you can see that
the clustering from layer to layer in
backprop and also in DFA is better and
better so the reason why back prop is
good maybe it's just that because it
also really induces clusterings like
this I don't know maybe back prop does
even does something on top of that
because I mean back prop has all the
properties of this and more right but
still this this is congra
with my hypothesis of what's happening
so what do they do with it
they take this algorithm and they apply
it to these architectures now let's for
example look at one of them this neural
View synthesis with neural radiance
fields so neural radiance feels this is
a type of model to do this task of where
you get a bunch of views of an object in
3d or you know a bunch of views around
an object and you're supposed to render
a new view and you can see that the DF a
parameter or the DFA updated nerve
neural radiance field model is pretty
close to the backpropagation
updated one you can see it's a bit more
blurry but it it works right and I think
the this paper is really trying to show
that look this works it doesn't work you
know extremely well but it works and it
works on on a level that hasn't been
seen before so here if you consider
these results higher as better on the
synthetic data set here even you can see
that if you have the same model with
back prop it performs better than with
DFA but the DFA for that model performs
better than these other baseline models
that have themselves been trained with
backpropagation so it's definitely in
the direction of being competitive and
that's the same thing they show with all
of these experiments so they've tie
these two graph networks they apply this
to transformers and as I said it's it's
not there yet you see that so in the
transformers they have these settings
were a macro they just use it DFA for
the individual blocks and micro they use
it for each layer and I already told you
that you still in the attention
mechanism you still have to use back
prop within the attention mechanism but
it is much more of a plausible algorithm
than the back propagation through the
entire network
and they show that if they appropriately
tweak the hyper parameters they do get
into the direction of something that's
performant at least with this macro
strategy now this is nowhere close to
this is nowhere close to what the - what
the back propagation algorithm achieves
but it's sort of it's sort of an
indication that if the community could
work as much on this as it has worked on
back propagation then probably we'll
make a lot of like we could we could
push this to a place where it does
perform on par with back prop or very
close to it so I do invite you to go and
look at the experiments they have a lot
of lot of details on how they did it and
exactly how you have to change the
architectures to make DFA work and the
hyper parameters and so on so that's
really cool and they have some more
outputs right here of the view synthesis
and so on yeah if you are interested in
that thing I again I don't want to
disrespect it it's just I don't think
there is much point in me going over it
it's the results are always sort of the
same that DFA it's not there yet but
it's a good direction yeah I hope this
was informative let me know if you
disagree about my assessment of DFA I
could be completely wrong or you know I
yeah or or this could be like well known
to people already so yeah see you next
time